my wife hates it when I change the words
to her favorite songs
it's her favorite love song of all time
[Music]
shoulder
and I had to learn how to do things with
my left hand and not everything was that
sweet
well I checked into my hotel room
shut the door and close the blinds
I opened the laptop
cut out the lotion it's time to treat
myself right
and I started in up and down motion
but something was definitely off
it was real Herky jerky nothing was
working like a hand job from Michael J
fox
okay well if you didn't like that part
you're gonna hate the next one ready
and it ended up way more
when I used my left hand
my dick was bruised and battered it
looked just like Chris Brown's
girlfriend
[Applause]
took a beating yay
that's right